[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
for today's video we're going to be
diving into the world of potions
in the harry potter universe there seems
to be a potion for everything
one to regrow your bones one to make you
lucky one to age you
and evil one to make you laugh
hysterically because of this
hogwarts places an emphasis on learning
potions from a very young age
and students are taught by skilled
potioneers like horus slughorn
and severus snape however though potion
making is useful
it certainly isn't easy potion making is
a very methodical process
that requires the correct mixing and
stirring of ingredients
at the right times and temperatures
being careful to balance all the serums
and liquids with magical properties
while already an art form in and of
itself
severus snape took it to a new level and
literally rewrote his potions textbook
under the alias the half-blood prince
during his time at school
he was the most skilled potioneer of his
age and was able to brew countless
powerful potions but one thing that i've
always wondered is
what are the most powerful potions in
this video i'm going
to attempt to rank some of the most
powerful potions
and alchemical solutions from the harry
potter world
number 15. a rampant potion the a
rumpant potion is a potion made from
various
erumpent parts known to be used in
potion making
erumpants are of course huge magical
african beasts
resembling a rhinoceros that we actually
see on screen
in the fantastic beasts film various
erumpent parts
such as the horn and tail are commonly
used in potion making
and the erumpent potion is essentially a
bomb
a highly explosive brew that explodes
upon touch
number 14. garretting gas garrison gas
is a colorless potion
that induces choking and possibly
suffocation
anyone exposed to the gas will find
themselves choking and
as a result may suffocate the gas will
catch the neck of anyone that passes
through it
the potion gets the name from the word
garrett which is a weapon commonly used
to strangle someone number 13. drink of
despair
the drink of despair aka the emerald
potion
is a concoction that places the consumer
in extreme pain
it famously appears in the cave in the
half blood prince
when harry and dumbledore are out
searching for horcruxes
the potion is a vicious concoction that
brought even dumbledore to his knees
and it was used by voldemort to protect
his horcruxes
number 12 draft of living death from the
textbook for advanced potion making
the draft of living death brings upon
its shrinker a very powerful sleep
that can last indefinitely this draft is
very dangerous if not
used with caution this is an extremely
dangerous potion
execute with maximum caution the potion
essentially places the consumer
in a state of sleep so deep that it
makes it seem as though they have died
it's discussed in the books and films by
both snape and slughorn
and psychon even had this to say in
reference to the brew
that harry had made i dare say that one
drop would kill us all
number 11 mopsis potion the mopsis
potion
is a powerful potion that appears to
give the drinker seer like powers
such as the ability to see into the
future additionally
it has been expressed that the potion
gives people the ability to manipulate
objects telekinetically
it's named after the greek seer mopsis
number 10
ex-stimular potion the x-stimulo potion
is a sky blue potion that boosts the
spell power of a single spell cast
it contains ray and blood grainian hair
snowdorp
and bitterroot though the potion can
only be applied to a single spell cast
its power should not be underestimated
as it can enhance the properties of
already very powerful spells number 9
rudimentary body potion
the rudimentary body potion helps
restore non-corporeal wizards to
rudimentary bodies
as we move through the course of the
films and books we see voldemort's
physical form
transition from something requiring a
host in the first film
to some semblance of an independent
physical form in the fourth
he basically goes from ghosts like wisp
to creepy baby that wormtale has to
carry around
and while his body was weak it was a
body nonetheless even capable of
wielding a wand
and casting a few spells the transition
into this new physical form
was the result of the rudimentary body
potion a potion invented by voldemort
that contained two
ingredients unicorn's blood and nagini's
venom
number eight regeneration potion the
true return of voldemort occurred
when he was given the regeneration
potion a potion that helps to restore
non-corporeal wizards to their bodies it
is an old piece of dark magic
that required three things bone of
father flesh of servant
and blood of foe to create this potion
wormtail and party crouch jr
helped voldemort to source these
ingredients they were able to use
wormtails flesh
voldemort's father's bone and harry's
blood all of the ingredients were then
placed inside of a cauldron
and voldemort's rudimentary form was
placed inside
after being placed inside voldemort was
able to return to his old
powerful physical form number seven
invisibility potion
the function of this potion is in the
name it allows the drinker to become
invisible
it's a silver bubbly potion that can be
used as an alternative
to the invisibility cloak or the
disillusionment charm
which served the same purpose
considering how useful the invisibility
cloak was for harry
and how useful being invisible can be in
general i think that it's deserving of
this placement
on the list number 6. veritas serum
let's let snape
explain this one it is verita's serum a
truth potion so powerful
that three drops would have you spilling
your innermost secrets for this entire
class to hear
veritas serum is essentially a truth
serum that shows up quite a bit in the
books and films
and i'm sure you can see why the ability
to force someone to tell the truth and
reveal their secrets
makes this an extremely powerful potion
number 5
polyjuice potion the polyjuice potion
which is a complex and time-consuming
concoction
is best left to highly skilled witches
and wizards it enables the consumer to
assume the physical appearance of
another person
as long as they have first procured part
of that individual's body
to add to the brew the effect of the
potion is only temporary
and depending on how well it has been
brewed may last anything from between 10
minutes
and 12 hours you can change age sex
and race by taking the polyjuice potion
but not
species the apologies potion is perhaps
most known to be used by party crouch
junior
when he impersonates madai moody and
teaches defense against the dark arts
it's an extremely powerful potion with
endless possibilities
number four gregory's anxious unction
gregory's anxious unction
was a powerful smoky green potion
invented by gregory the smarmy
a talented potioneer from the 12th
century the potion causes the drinker to
believe that
whomever gave the potion to them is
their best friend you can imagine the
power that something like this would
bear
given that it could swing allegiances in
an instant number three amortentia
a step up from gregory's anxious unction
is amortentia
a powerful love potion that causes
extreme infatuation
or obsession from the drinker amortentia
is the most powerful love potion in the
world
it is distinctive for its mother of
pearl sheen and steam rises from the
potion and spirals
and mortensia smells different to each
person according to what attracts them
while inducing friendship can be a
powerful way to change allegiances
inducing love is even more powerful
amortentia is considered by some
to be the most dangerous potion of all
as it doesn't even induce
actual love just a semblance of love
that has derived from strong obsession
we see and hear of amortentia in the
harry potter franchise quite a bit
and it can make people do some very
uncharacteristically strange
things number two elixir of life the
elixir of life was a potion created from
the philosopher's stone
by nicholas flamel that extends the
taker's life
both nicolas flamel and his wife took
this potion
for most of their lives and it allowed
them to live upwards of 600 years old
the potion was made from one of the most
powerful magical artifacts in existence
and a potion that allows you to live
forever in my eyes
is certainly one of the most powerful
number one
felix felicis also known as liquid luck
felix felicis is a magical potion that
makes the taker successful
in all their endeavors felix felicis is
in my opinion
the most powerful potion of all because
its possibilities are limitless
whatever you try to use it for you will
be successful at which means that with
it you should be able to achieve
almost well anything it was created by
potioneer sigmund budge
during the 16th century and he dubbed it
his crowning achievement
of his career and that's it for this
video what do you guys think of this
list
which potions would you add or remove
how would you reorder them
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry